Until now,
we've given you a demo, but what we're
really interested in is production.
The goal of this course is to
get you ready for scaling and
managing containers in production.
So, let's do that now.
That's where deployments come in.
See, deployments are a declarative
way to say what goes where.
The used in four state is
given by the end user.
Behind the scenes deployments use
a Copa90's concept called replica sets
to ensure that the current number
of Pods equals the desired number.
When it comes to managing Pods,
deployment destruct away the low level
details like what node is my Pod on,
where is it running.
Pods are tied to
the lifetime of the Node.
So, when the Node goes away,
so does the Pod.
Instead of managing that we can
use deployments to make our
life a little easier.
In the example on screen you'll see
that we have a Pod with one replica.
Well, what happens when we change the
number of replicas from one to three.
Our deployment will go ahead and
ensure that the number of replicas in
production matches are desired state.
This means that even if a Node goes
down like Node3 just in our example,
the deployment will start a new Pod and
find somewhere to put it for us and
that's pretty cool.
It's time to combine everything we've
learned so far about Pods and service
and the breaking up the Monolith App in
a smaller services using deployments.